we're concerned with what we call social
resilience which is really about the
tools that societies provide to their
members to develop lives that are more
fulfilling and also to and to face the
challenges that neoliberalism trolls
their way the very strict if you like
pure forms of neoliberalism that were
first articulated met all of these forms
of resilience resilience is has to do
with the ways in which people respond to
the problem and what we're interested in
doing is looking for the sources of
social resilience why are some
communities more resilient in the face
of adverse changes while others are not
people who study resilience typically
are looking at for instance twins you
know why is one better able to face the
challenges that he encounters than the
other
we use the term resilience because we
are struck by the many many ways in
which individuals communities societies
institutions they were put under a lot
of stress by neoliberal ideas and by
neoliberal reforms but they didn't just
roll over and die they put up a fight
people show resilience when in the face
of adversity in the face of risks they
perform well on important indicators
like well-being or school performance or
health social resilience as we see it is
really the capacity of social groups or
communities maybe even entire nations to
preserve sustain their well-being in the
face of adverse changes I'm quite
impressed by the ability of local
communities as well as
provinces in Canada and the national
government here in Canada to to fight to
preserve many of the the things that
that we most value and and so social
resilience is is just in part the the
fact that we are we are actors we are
agents in our in our own lives not just
individually but collectively